bienvenue pour le 78 lactu il est
l'heure de votre nouvelle édition du
Journal de la rédaction tout de suite
les titres de ce vendredi 11 avril Alain
schmi démissionnaire Pierre Bédier
reprend la tête du département des
yelines 5 ans après une condamnation qui
avait entraîné son inégibilité comment
pas c'est sa prise de pouvoir ce matin
nous le verrons dans un instant vivre
avec un cancer au-delà de la maladie
c'est aussi subir une forte
discrimination sociale c'est le bilan de
l'enquête menée par la Ligue contre le
cancer qui vient d'être présentée et
puis nous reviendrons en fin d'édition
comme chaque semaine comme chaque
vendredi sur l'essentiel de l'actualité
depuis le début de la semaine du message
d'chef prévention sur l'importance de
toujours se protéger face au sida à la
mobilisation de parents d'élèves contre
une fermeture de classe à plaisir avant
de débuter ce journal un chiffre celui
du nombre d'embauches envisagé en î de
France par les entreprises du privé et
du public
287000 près de 60000 établissements ont
été sondés par Pôle Emploi le constat la
propension à recruter augmente dans
l'ensemble des secteurs d'activité à
l'exception de l'industrie
manufacturière les activités de services
auront à cette année le plus besoin de
main d'œuvre politique et le retour aux
affaires de Pierre Bédier beaucoup de
monde ce vendredi au Conseil Général des
Yvelines après la démission effective
hier d'alin schmidz une démission qui
intervient seulement un ans avant les
prochaines cantonales de mars 2015
Pierre Bédier avait déjà été président
du conseil général entre 2005 et 2009 il
avait dû quitter son siège après avoir
été condamné pour délit d'initié et
prise illégale d'intérêt 5 ans plus tard
il est réélu 26 voix pour 9 voix contre
et de blanc et nul deux conseillèr
général étaient absentes et n'avait pas
donné de pouvoir Christine Boutin et
Fanny hervera à l'issue du vote pierre
Bédie a fait un discours politique où il
a défendu l'utilité des conseils
généraux il a évoqué un effort de
maîtrise de la dépense publique une
ambition pourer à bien des missions de
solidarité des actions également en
faveur de l'emploi il souhaite aussi la
création d'une agence départementale de
soutien aux communes rurales plus qu'un
discours d'installation c'est une vraie
nouvelle feuille de route qu' a soumise
aux
élusilités qui sont les miennes dans un
contexte difficile pour les
collectivités puisque le département le
département oui mais les communes qui
ont besoin des départements les
intercommunalités vont quand même être
matraqué par les projets du pouvoir
socialiste heureux de voir que tout ce
que j'ai fait va être repris et ce qui
m'a frappé c'est le mot ambition pour le
département à un moment même où dans son
discours de politique générale le
Premier ministre a a évoqué la
disparition des départements et je pense
que c'est au contraire quand c'est le le
devenir des département est aléatoire
qu'il faut être encore plus ambitieux au
service des ivelinois donc j'ai reçu le
message 5 sur 5 de Pierre Bédier un
sentiment de de de de tristesse
d'inachevé de la
partè
présidentm et puis quelque chose qui
ressemble avantage à ce que je disais
une révolution de palais qu' un
véritable exercice démocratique voilà
vous avez parlé même de manœuvre
politicienne oui je et je maintiens je
pense qu'il y a eu des pressions des
manœuvres politiciennes pour en arriver
là où on est arrivé aujourd'hui
effectivement vous l'avez deviné ce
matin il n'était pas uniquement question
du retour de Pierre de Pierre Bédier
dans les couloirs du conseil général les
élus évoquaient aussi les premières
annonce du nouveau chef du gouvernement
manuel Vals et ce dernier a en effet
évoqué sa volonté de faire disparaître
les départements et de réaliser ainsi
des économies importantes sur le
fonctionnement de l'État ce ne sont pas
les conseillers généraux qui ruinent la
nation a insisté le nouveau président
Bédier qui s'est voulu combatif sur ce
dossier ça n'est pas l'intérêt ni des
ivelinois ni des Français en règle
générale de supprimer les départements
j'aime l'histoire depuis de siècles que
les départements existent chaque fois
qu'on les a supprimé c'est pas la
première fois on les a recréé la
dernière fois c'était sous Vichi ils ont
même été obligés de les recréer quand
même voilà cette institution
départementale c'est un échelon
nécessaire la France n'est pas sur
administrée elle est mal administrée
mais ça coûte pas trop cher les conseils
généraux 1 milliè du budget du
département est consacré à ça qu'est-ce
qui coûte cher c'est le RSA c'est les
routes c'est les collèges on veut
supprimer tout ça va bien falloir des
fonctionner hein pour gérer ça c'est pas
39 élus qui ruinent la République quand
on nous dit attention suppression des
départements ceux qui disent ça sont les
mêmes que ceux qui avaient prévu les
conseillers territoriaux sont les mêmes
que ceux qui disaient qu'il y avait un
millefeuille trop important et sont les
mêmes que ceux qui disaient qu'il y
avait trop d'élus moi je pense que la
démocratie c'est d'avoir des élus et de
bien définir quelles sont leurs
compétences et à quel niveau ils doivent
travailler il y aura une réflexion
pendant les années qui viennent donc on
n'est pas dans la précipitation
justement là une réflexion pour les
années qui viennent sur l'avenir d'un
conseil départemental c'estàdire que que
font les élus à cet échelonlà ça ça me
semble important et et c'est ce matin
que les professionnels de l'action
sociale du conseil général ont choisi de
se faire entendre bonsoir Tristan
Fournet vous êtes secrétaire CGT du
conseil général des des ivelines
l'occasion était belle ce matin
justement de profiter de l'arrivée d'un
d'un nouveau président du retour de
Pierre Bédier pour se faire entendre
expliquez-nous les raisons de votre
revendication alors c'est clair que
l'occasion était belle puisque
l'ensemble des directeurs des cadres des
élus du Conseil Général était rassemblé
à l'Hôtel du Département euh donc
c'était quandme même le meilleur moment
pour se faire entendre dans la rue se
faire entendre dans la rue pourquoi
c'est parce que le le dialogue social
les rencontres qu'on a pu avoir avec les
représentants de l'institution n'ont pas
permis de débloquer la situation alors
que l'enjeu est majeur l'enjeu c'est une
dégradation des conditions de travail et
une dégradation du service rendu à la
population particulièrement pour sociaux
qui était qui était ce matin en train de
voilà oui donc les travailleurs sociaux
les agents administratifs les cadres
étaient dans la rue aussi avec nous he
pas que à l'hôtel du département donc la
filière médico-sociale foyer enfance
enfin il y avait une large
représentation du personnel on était à
peu près
600 manifestants sur 1000 agents de
l'action sociale médico-sociale
qu'est-ce qui vous inquiète aujourd'hui
c'est le gel des postes notamment alors
c'est ça le problème c'est qu'on voit
d'un côté on voit une augmentation des
besoins sociaux et de la charge de
travail par exemple le le RSA le nombre
de bénéficiaires RA augmenté de 7,3 %
l'année dernière c'est une moyenne
nationale au Conseil Général des
ivelines on pas au travers de cette
augmentation de nombre de bénéficiaires
de minimas sociaux le taux de chômage il
augmente c'est une réalité donc les
besoins ils augmentent en visavis on a
une diminution des moyens il gèle les
postes il ne renouvelle pas les contrats
les départs à la retraite sont pas
remplacés et derrière il suppriment les
emplois donc on a déjà connu des pertes
d'emploi par le passé mais là il y a une
accélération massive de ce nombre de
pertes c'est insupportable dans les
servic combien de temps qu'est-ce qui a
entraîné c'est justement c'est cette
accélération pour vous alors
l'accélération elle on nous on la situe
clairement à partir de janvier où en
fait la masse salariale a été votée en
décembre à l'assemblée départementale
elle permet pas d'être à effectif
constant ce qu'ils ont voté permet pas
donc ils sont obligés de voilà de
supprimer des postes le DRH donc au
niveau de la CGT on a été reçu le 6 mars
par le DRH qui a dit il y a du gras dans
les services c'est vrai que quand on dit
à des collègues bah il y a du gras dans
les services il faut dégraisser ça fait
vraiment pas plaisir donc dans la rue il
y avait des collègues avec les pancartes
avec leur date de fin de contrat
j'espère qu'on sera parce que derrière
c'est pas que des postes c'est pas que
de l'emploi qu'on entend donc le nouveau
président du conseil général dire il
faut préserver l'emploi défendre
l'emploi qu' le fasse déjà dans ses
services et je voudrais c'est qu'il soit
qu' aujourd'hui on soit tous entendus
que les 600 personnes dans la rue et
tous les les autres collègues soient
entendus là-dessus sur cette question
c'est que le service rendu il est
dégradé al justement quellees
conséquence pour votre travail au
quotidien ça se traduit comment vous
êtes moins présent vous pouvezm répondre
aux sollicitations des dossiers qui
prennent du retard ça se traduit comment
alors oui il y a des dossiers qui
prennent prenent du retard quand on
parle de dossier qui par du prennent du
retard derrière c'est de protection de
l'enfance dont il s'agit par exemple
c'est des rapports de protection de
l'enfance c'est pas rien en terme de
retard de courrier c'est de la
prévention qui se fait plus en terme de
prévention de l'enfance on est dans
l'urgence donc on est sur les mesures
uniquement de placement mais plus de
prévention pour éviter justement le
placement et même pour ne plus avoir les
moyens de préparer le retour c'est des
consultations PMI qui se font pas donc
c'est enfin voilà c'est c'est c'est tout
ça qui se fait les il y a des
professionnels qui étaient spécialisés
qui disparaissent en terme de mission
les CESF par exemple pouveit être dans
l'accompagnement éducatif budgétaire
monter les dossiers de surendettement et
pour palier les postes qui sont
supprimés on les affecte sur des postes
d'assistante social donc on leur change
leur mission et le service derrière bah
forcément pour le public il se présente
rendez-vous dans un mois quand c'est la
détresse des personnes qui font la
démarche de venir et puis on dit bah ça
sera dans un mois c'est insupportable et
pour l'usager et pour l'agent qui est en
charge de passer ce message quoi ce
matin nous avons rencontré Daniel level
il est délégué au personnel
départemental au Conseil Général des
ivelines voici sa réponse à vos
revendications je les ai reçu hier matin
comme je le fais à chaque fois avant
chaque mouvement de grève les seuls gels
que nous avons bloqué actuellement ce
sont les cadres de façon à prévoir une
éventuelle réorganisation souhaitée par
le président il vienn en parler dans son
discours je n'ai pas de de de
commentaires supplémentaires à faire le
travail réalisé par les travailleurs
sociaux dans les différents territoires
même s'il peut y avoir des difficultés
parfois de recrutement de renouvellement
de contrats elles sont gérées donc il y
a pas il y a pas l'ensemble des soucis
il y a pas de plan social dans ce
département d'accord estce que on
l'impression que leur condition de
travail se dégrade dans certains
secteurs elle est cert un peu dégradée
par des difficultés de recrutement c'est
pas simple de trouver le le bon
personnel que nous attendons mais
globalement bien les missions du conseil
général sont rempli auprès de la
population triste en fourné je voudrais
vous faire réagir pour la CGT sur ce qui
vient d'être dit pas de plan social et
pas d'inquiétude sur la qualité non plus
du service rendu c'est insupportable
d'entendre qu'il y a pas d'impact sur
enfin s'il y a 600 personnes dans la rue
c'est pas parce que il y avait juste un
gel de certains postes et puis qui avait
pas d'impact sur le au sein du service
il y a un nombre d'arrêt maladie qui est
croissant il y a même un nombre
d'incidents et d'agression de fait
d'agression quoi au sein des services
parce qu'il y a un vrai malêtre qui est
partagé quoi en terme de gel oui ils ont
reconnu qu'il y avait un gel des
catégories A quand on est venu au niveau
de la CGT avec les chiffres on a fait
une consultation dans les services les
catégories C c'est gelé également
catégorie B également on leur montre ces
chiffres là ces données ils ont reconnu
qu'effectivement ça concernait tout le
monde donc où aujourd'hui ces marches
arrière finalement on va dire bah c'est
plus qu'une seule catégorie et on aurait
gagné sur une petite partie mais
clairement c'est pas le cas ça montre
que la question du dialogue est pas
réglée donc on espère qu'avec le nouveau
président on aurait une on aura une
réponse très rapide et qui vont mesurer
l'ampleur de la colère au sein des
services mais pour autant on risque
aussi de vous répondre qu'il faut faire
des économies que la période est
difficile qu'on parle aussi de d'une
disparition de des conseils généraux
quelle il va falloir faire des économies
malgré tout alors oui alors faire des
économies euh oui on peut faire des
économies enfin par exemple enfin nous
on a fait des propositions aussi en
terme d'économie euh on est conscient
que en terme de baisse de droit de
mutation de dotation
collectivité territorial enfin il y a
fort à dire d'ailleurs demain au niveau
de la CGT on est également dans la rue
pour contre la politique d'austérité
nationale qui met en situation difficile
les collectivités territoriales mais
pour autant au département ils ont voté
il y a près d'un mois 1 million d'euros
à général électrique c'est une
multinationale qui fait un chiffre
d'affaires en milliard d'euros 10è côté
en bourse alors là il y aurait des
économies à faire on voit pas en quoi le
Conseil général pourrait verser un
million là-dessus et de l'autre côté
dire bah il faut supprimer des postes
pour une compétence fondamentale quoi du
conseil général et le dialogue est en
difficile aujourd'hui vous allez mener
d'autres actions spécifiquement dans le
département c'est déjà
prévu on est déterminé c'est sûr qu'on
est déterminé que la colère j'espère
qu'ils l'auront mesurer c'est que les
agents aussi sont déterminés aujourd'hui
c'était l'action sociale il y a d'autres
services qui sont concernés l'ensemble
des directions peuvent être concerné au
niveau de la CGT on a estimé que ça
pouvait concerner 8 % de l'effectif en 3
ans en moins il y a un plan de
modernisation pour les collèges donc en
intersyndical on intervient sous forme
d'une pétition pour dénoncer ce qu'on a
fait pour l'action sociale là mais pour
l'ensemble des directions pourraiit
mener des actions effectivement merci
trist en fourn pour la CGT d'être venu
sur ce plateau je le rappelle les
professionnels de l'action social au
Conseil Général était dans la rue ce
matin pour dénoncer notamment le le gel
des postes merci à vous on en revient la
politique toujours à trrappe dans une
ambiance beaucoup plus calme au dernier
conseil municipal qui se tenait hier
jeudi soir la semaine dernière lors de
l'installation des équipes du socialiste
guimalandin le vote qui devait être une
simple formalité est devenu l'expression
d'un fort mécontentement de la part
d'élus écartés des mandats d'adjoint une
occasion pour l'opposition de parler
d'un système à bout de souffle rappelons
que dans cette ville très ancré à gauche
pourtant l'abstention a été forte sur
les deux tours et que l'UMP a réussi à
totaliser 30 % des
suffrages nouveau conseil municipal à
trrape ce jeudi 10 avril et une équipe
majoritaire cette fois-ci à l'unisson le
coup de sang du maire guimalandin semble
en tout cas en apparence avoir porté ses
fruits la semaine dernière lors du vote
interne pour désigner les adjoints des
élus de sa propre liste près d'un tiers
avait en effet voté contre les noms
proposés ce qui aurait poussé les deal
socialistes à recadrer ses troupes en
aparté sur le fond ce serait les postes
attribués aux nouveaux ent au sein de
l'assemblée locale au dépend de ses
membres plus anciens qui aurait du mal à
être accepté ce conseil municipal il a
un petit peu confirmé ce qu'on craignait
c'est qu'il y a aujourd'hui un climat de
défiance entre l'équipe municipale
actuelle qui a été réélu et une partie
des trapistes alors nous ce climat de
défiance on le dénonce tout simplement
parce qu'on a l'impression
qu'aujourd'hui on a essayé de faire
pression sur les élus de trapistes pour
faire la place à des élus qui sont
parachutés dans une logique purement
politicienne et donc là effectivement
c'est quelque chose qu'on qu'on dénonce
c'est plus précisément l'influence
grandissante du ministre mon sur la
répartition des délégations qui est visé
ce dernier était d'ailleurs absent ce
jeudi soir le maire guimalandin qui se
dit toujours agacé de cette situation
n'a pas souhaité réagir ni lors de la
séance ni devant notre caméra son
entourage évoque un épihénomène on
notera cependant parmi les autres
absents à ce conseil Cécile Maquel
ancienne adjointe à la jeunesse lors du
précédent mandat elle n'a jeudi soir
donné aucune procuration peut-être en
signe de contestation autre opposant a
siégé au sein du conseil municipal de
trappe Luc miseray pour le Front de
gauche il parle d'une situation inédite
et grave faut pas qu'on s'étonne après
ou qu'on fasse mine de s'étonner qu'il y
a autant d'abstentionnisme qu' on est
inquiet je le dis légitimement sen faut
moi je fais pas d'effets de manche il y
en a qui font des effets de manche qui
quittent les débats moi je fais pas
d'effet de manche mais je suis
véritablement inquiet quant à la
démocratie en général et ici en
particulier prochaine séance pour les
élus trapistes le 28 avril reste à voir
si l'unité affiche ich se confirmera ou
finira par s'effriter au gré des
délibérations santé société à présent
les difficultés au quotidien pour les
personnes atteintes du cancer ne sont
pas à chercher uniquement du côté
médical le regard de la société cruel
c'est le bilan d'une enquête menée par
la Ligue contre le cancer explication et
témoignage avec ce reportage de yolen
Torz et de Jonathan
vilman lorsqu'on parle de cancer on
évoque avant tout son aspect médical
pourtant la maladie a un impact tout
aussi important sur la vie sociale et
économique des personnes touchées pour
lutter contre ces difficultés la Ligue
nationale contre le cancer a mis en
place il y a 4 ans le dos passe c'est le
dispositif d'observation des actions
sociales le comité des ivelines a
présenté les résultats pour l'année 2013
et l'un des constats importants c'est la
difficulté du retour à l'emploi pour les
malades dans un une période où il y a un
taux de chômage extrêmement important
des employeurs qui de temps en temps se
dire mais qu'est-ce que je vais faire de
cette personne qui a été malade et qui
n'aura pas le rendement
r que je souis ou qui suite à des arrêts
itératif n'est plus tout à fait au
courant de ce qu'on fait maintenant
voilà par exemple des difficultés
réelles il y a 2 ans alors qu'elle
travaillait au service communication
d'une grande banque française Mathilde
apprend qu'elle a un cancer du sein
au-delà de l'isolement ce qu'elle a mal
vécu c'est la difficulté à évaluer le
moment où elle allait pouvoir revenir
travailler rapidement on m'a dit mais
alors quand est-ce que tu reviens quand
est-ce que tu reviens et ils comprennent
pas l'entreprise a du mal à admettre que
vous vous ne soyez pas capable de dire
que vous ne soyez pas dans le même état
de fatigue d'une semaine à l'autre que
un jour ça va et que 3 jours après ça va
plus et ça c'est c'est extrêmement
compliqué à gérer déjà soi-même mais en
plus à faire admettre à un service dans
une dans une entreprise ou d'abord
revenu en temps partiel thérapeutique
elle a finalement décidé de quitter son
entreprise actuellement en rémission
elle est devenue auto-entrepreneuse dans
l'événementiel pour palier à ses Faé de
retour au travail le dispositif avance
notamment une solution mieux anticiper
la reprise de l'activité et en parler
avec son médecin du travail beaucoup de
gens ont peur d'aller voir leur médecin
de travail parce qu'ils se disent il va
devoir parler il va tout raconter à ma
direction des ressources humaines à mon
employeur et cetera non le médecin du
travail est tenu au secret professionnel
comme tous les médecins et donc ça ça
n'existe pas et vraiment ce sont les des
acteurs extrêmement importants pour
permettre justement dans les meilleures
conditions possibles le retour à
l'emploi d'après l'enquête dans les
ivelines 48 % des malades atteints d'un
cancer déclarent avoir une situation
économique
difficile comme chaque vendredi nous
revenons à présent sur les principales
informations de la semaine et tout
d'abord jeudi la colère des parents
d'élèves de plaisir la possibilité d'une
fermeture de classe dans un
établissement de la ville les inquiète
et il se mobilise une pétition circule
depuis une semaine les précisions
dans cette école primaire de plaisir les
parents d'élèves se mobilisent car ils
craignent la fermeture d'une classe en
raison de la baisse des effectifs
l'école primaire compte une centaine
d'enfants il ne serait plus que 96 à la
rentrée prochaine actuellement CIN
classes sont ouvertes une classe par
niveau ce qui impliquerait en cas de
fermeture un double niveau et pas
acceptable pour les parents ça pourrait
faire un CP CM2 ou CP ce qui serait plus
difficile aux maîtresses de faire
différents niveaux
s'occuper du d'une moitié de la classe
et de l'autre aussi à côté les élèves
devront être beaucoup plus autonome ce
ce qui n'est pas tous les jours facile
déjà avec avec une une classe normale
sans sans double niveau on aurait des
classes tout de suite de presque 20 25
26 si c'est pas 30 élèves des fois une
pétition circule depuis une semaine sans
qu' signatures ont été recueillis une
mobilisation qui intervient alors que se
tenait ce jeudi à l'inspection
académique des Yvelines le conseil
technique spécial départemental chargé
notamment de la présentation de la
future carte scolaire et cette carte
scolaire dans les écoles des Yvelines à
la rentrée 2014 a été dévoilé par
l'Inspection Académique 33 postes
supplémentaires alloués au département
pour le primaire afin de permettre
l'ouverture de 14 nouvelles classes
notamment à manie pour l'école
maternelle corau ou encore à guilloncour
dans trois écoles maternelles Morau
Langevin et Triolet mais aussi une école
élémentaire lursa mercredi nous nous
sommes intéressés dans le journal au
petit boulot étudiant trouver un boulot
pour l'été lorsque l'on est étudiant
c'est toujours un moment angoissant mais
pour simplifier les choses Yveline
Information Jeunesse a tenu un grand
forum c'était à l'Hôtel de Ville Olivier
Maniscalco et Patrick Jacques de dixmud
était sur place ils ont constaté non
seulement le succès de cette opération
mais également la forte demande pour
aller travailler à
l'étranger comeétienne qui écoute avec
attention les conseils d'Olivier ils
étaient déjà près de 300 sans étudiants
à la mi-journée ce mercredi à la mairie
de Versailles pour le forum job d'été un
forum qui permet aux jeunes de
rencontrer directement les employeurs ou
d'être aidé pour la rédaction des CV et
lettres de motivation une tâche pas
toujours évidente au premier abord
surtout sur le stand job à l'étranger
particulièrement plébiscité mais pour
être embauché dans un autre pays il faut
forcément s'adapter les Anglais ont des
règles qui sont inverses en français
c'est-à-dire le CV peut être sur
plusieurs pages mais la lettre du
motivation sur une seule page et donc ça
c'est toujours un petit point de détail
sur lesquel les Français ne sont pas
souvent au courant et donc nous notre
mission ça va être justement de les
informer et de les aider sur la
rédaction et et notamment aussi de de
corriger tout ce qui est les petites
coquilles et compagnie ça ça
arrive les jeunes repartent avec des
réponses à leurs questions des offres
d'emploi et surtout rassuré quant à leur
prétentions de départ à l'étranger
d'arriver un peu les mains vit puis de
nous dire bah oui rien qu'avec ton CV
c'est c'est pas mal tu parles bien je
pense que oui on va t'orienter sur
différents sites et puis il y a plus
qu'à postuler et puis même si on arrive
pas sur les sites ils ont ils ont un
gros livre où il a déjà des offres qui
sont qui sont disponibles c'est un côté
ration en France selon l'Observatoire de
la vie étudiante 35 % des jeunes ont un
job à côté de leurs
études et pour revoir tous nos
reportages rendez-vous sur le site
internet de TVfil le Replay est
accessible en permanence et gratuitement
depuis votre ordinateur votre tablette
ou votre smartphone je vous propose à
présent de revenir sur le bilan du site
d'action avec un extrait du J oural de
mardi nous étions en ligne avec jérô
Andr de chef prévention il en est le
président association qui lutte contre
le VIH il réagissait par téléphone au 5
millions d'euros de promesses de don
pour le Sidaction mais il faisait aussi
un constat le sida aujourd'hui ne fait
plus peur 5 million c'est pas mal en
tout cas c'est stable par rapport à
l'année dernière on aimerait bien qu'il
y ait effectivement plus d'augmentation
donc pour le Sidaction néanmoins on se
rend bien compte que le sida aujourd'hui
ce n'est plus une cause qui donc fait
penser aux Français qu'il faut encore
donner malheureusement c'est important
de le rappeler on meurt encore
aujourd'hui du sida et c'est vrai qu'il
y a pas mal de problématiques qui sont
lié donc à cela notamment par le fait
que les gens donc n'utilisent plus trop
le préservatif c'est pour ça d'ailleurs
qu'on sort prochainement une application
iPhone pour géolocaliser donc ce type
donc d'outil de prévention qui est donc
le préservatif 5 million d'euros de
promesse de don au niveau national à
quoi sert cet argent justement
concrètement à développer aussi la
recherche les actions de sensibil
rappeler qu'il faut toujours et encore
se protéger exactement c'est important
de souligner que l'association faction
qui est une association donc un fond
donc qui va permettre à des associations
mais aussi à des chercheurs de faire
progresser donc la lutte contre le sida
la recherche en général on on dit
souvent strictement de manière très
stricte 1 € reversé donc aussi d'action
c'est 50 centimes pour les associations
donc de recherche euh donc ça va être
des chercheurs he de l'inerme et autres
et 50 centimes donc qui est reversé donc
à une association pour des projets des
projets de lutte contre donc le sida et
et notamment pour faire progresser aussi
la prévention en France n'oubliez donc
pas le 110 pour donner encore la
plateforme est ouverte jusque au 15
avril et puis également la possibilité
de donner en ligne sur le
saction.org pour un nouveau point
complet sur l'actualité locale
rendez-vous lundi même heure avec
Catherine zulato on se quitte en musique
puisque ce vendredi à la batterie agui
encour se produira kit crole and the
coconuts vous avez peut-être oublié ce
nom mais en tout cas pas ces tub mélange
de funk et de sonorité latine petit
rappel avec indicot grand succès des
années 80 très bon
weekend
may
I
some
and